what's going on reject nation i'm greg
i'm john oh you usually introduce me i'm
olivia woman
olivia i'm woman we are going to watch
today the boys season two episode
four make sure to subscribe and click
that notification bell so you get
notified when our reaction for the next
boys episode is up here on youtube as a
friendly reminder this is gonna qualify
as reaction highlights we can't show the
whole show
obviously full-length reaction watch
alongs will be over at our patreon page
we can sync up with the time code thank
you guys so much to everyone who has
already joined our patreon page and
everyone who's joined our patreon page
because they wanted to watch along with
the boys over there we cover
so many television shows that have the
option for watch along or reaction
highlights included
i'm showing all these images on screen
because i just don't want to
list them off for you right now but oh
my god such an over abundance of shows
i think i've talked enough now to allow
all the images to show on screen
and last but not least eric over at nerd
chronic thank you so much for
editing this for us he's editing our
highlights and watch along he's a
main editor for movie trivia schmoedes
editor for a bunch of other reactors
he edited this sec uh now we want to
talk about it
this is all cgi from the intro
[Music]
witnesses who caught a glimpse of the
killer described him as
dead-eyed and unemotional
i think you did
frenchy see i was a little confused that
they already were
not doing stuff i know i thought they
already were but
okay i guess they're not i have been
shouting
what no this is a flashback
or a dream sequence something i was
beginning to worry
oh she's got milk she got that milky
boobies out too
we want you to make a cameo and we got
the best cameo in mind for you
i found becca or at least our best guess
where she is
bought facility over to the teeth we had
a deal
i didn't come fruit jesus butcher i'm
just giving it to you
oh um i hope you stay alive old lady
yeah stop how did i say anything i'll
tell you one thing
you wouldn't put up with this see yeah
one little raise of the eyebrow and you
would have knocked them all back
i wish i didn't incinerate your face
james back change back
for so long before it really hurts
change
the [ __ ] back now doppelganger
i love you i love you
i'm so twisted dude doppelganger was
shoving his fingers
blender's mouth
oh i don't know who i'm more scared who
shows up homeland or storefront
like who's scarier to me right now
no more lies i'm not with
him but if you want to kill me
because i'm not a murderer and i won't
straight up
execute someone then go ahead
am i lying
man homelander
almond joys um
hi
[Laughter]
um do you mean william butcher
just uh run a facial recognition search
you can join me
she can't come with us you wish she's
chipped so i have a second cousin who
lives around there
i could tell ra that i'm going to visit
no
even her standing here yeah maybe he's
right
if they find out you're in north
carolina and she's there they can put
the connection together you know
like she needs this
you mean you need this
shockwave is just here to talk about
vodka dots i swear to god
what the [ __ ] is vaudford it's outreach
for toddlers apparently they're getting
obese
well [ __ ] i [ __ ] love fat kids
tell them yet i [ __ ] love pancakes
i thought we were gonna have a strategy
meeting hey train you're out oh
oh out of the seven he did great
but we're going in a different direction
oh he's gonna start helping huey and
starlight
i do want you to know though this was
really hard for me okay
there's nothing personal we'll always be
friends oh
hey hey this ain't no little vegas road
trip okay you only know no date either
this is a mission he called about baskin
robbins
i don't know who's identifying every
sunday after church
this place had 31 flavors and that man
would taste
each sounds like my dad
my ass was so embarrassed i shot him in
the head that wishing the floor would
just open up and
swallow me whole that's gonna happen
sometime
of course now i give a year off my life
just to be able to see that man going
through spoon after spoon just
one last time dude
great monologue when did he
16 years ago oh get over it
yeah what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
we're on a mission here
[ __ ] no no no no no no no no
no no no helping people you can right
now
yeah i agree i agree
that's an interesting conflict
that's how i feel for shows i just state
my feelings out loud
i would kill myself in front of ryan and
my last words would be your father did
this to me
oh the fence the same way that i come in
wow you can't how do you avoid the
cameras
i don't understand don't you got no
powers
no i i mean oh no yes but i'm not i'm
not raising him like oh no no no
oh no oh god you sure it's not [ __ ]
compact
i'm really curious to see how he handles
the whole thing with ryan
damn man almond joy paid for this one
is that an almond nobody likes zombie
joy
oh this i like all the toys
oh yeah i walk around the seventh tower
just wondering if homelander is waiting
around every corner to kill me he is
likely it's like a haunted house it's
like living with a loaded gun in my face
do you feel that way now
why he wouldn't protect you no
this is not what i wanted to see strong
sexual content
like my last boyfriend was obsessed with
edge urine
problem so he asked me to get one of
these with him
wowie two weeks later he broke up with
me
wow what is this thing we're cutting to
what are we cutting to exactly i have no
idea i'm not sure what this what this
wrap around is yet uh
i know you hate kids and all but i think
that he's pregnant
no i don't i don't hate kids but suit
kids
not a very good role model
well i like seeing a softer spot to him
take the seven for example we've got a
train he's a black man we got black noir
he um but he doesn't identify with it
really he's going to expose her
oh what a dick oh
how dare you
oh is it so hard to believe that i want
you two to be happy
yeah yeah yeah it is fair 100 i don't
trust it
it was during one of those summer rains
that you just knew was coming by the
smell in the air
my brother myron he was driving
hey your car was involved in a robbery
tonight
no it wasn't i had it i don't know
nothing about any robbery
confess
why are you doing this to me lady ain't
you supposed to be the hero i am a hero
for killing a black piece of [ __ ] like
you jesus
christ
oh boy
i wanted to go to the police oh [ __ ]
nobody's seen her since 1979 i mean
she's probably dead by now
that's her right there that's
i thought her voice sounded familiar
don't read the comments homelander who
the [ __ ] do you
think you think i don't see it
this constant need to be loved by
everyone is kind of pathetic
but um yay
okay okay
i'm just trying to help really
how by taking what's mine you can't win
the whole country anymore
no one can you don't need 50 million
people to
love you you need five million people
[ __ ] pissed
hmm you're gonna find a way to get rid
of him
i know it it won't be in an obvious way
and it won't be right away but you will
oh no billy i know oh [ __ ]
i believe her man yeah i definitely
believe it's a billion dollars
oh hopefully you're not gonna let him go
and then vaught raises him without a
mother right
then we have homelander all over again
then there's two [ __ ] [ __ ] in
this one
yeah that's a good point that's a good
point again start a new family yeah
regarding this goddamn place is going to
be here in 60 seconds
i'm sorry yeah i totally get where she's
coming from though oh yeah 100 percent
like i really do yeah i'm a feminist
no but i'm also very sexual what
is this and i don't see that as
contradictory
thank you so much anytime it was really
great meeting you
really great
she was like hands down the winner yeah
not even a contest
it's cassandra it's about rehabilitating
your image
and getting you back in the seven that
is what you want
oh jesus christ
there you are
he's going to kill her yeah him or her
or he's doppelganger identified whatever
he identifies she identifies with
i don't judge i don't need anyone
but myself yeah yep
oh my word
[Music]
see how hot you what what
no this is not happening please go there
america's ass please do it i want
oh he's into it you're gonna look in
your own eyes when you
come wow
it's your strength he's still gonna go
yeah nah go through with it
uh oh never mind yeah
just pull that head off huh yep yep yep
i don't need
you oh
strange
oh
okay that was an episode for sure
it was uh pretty moody really heavy on
the the
feeling like a drama there's some
violent moments and stuff
it took its time like a pretty good
amount which is not something i usually
associate or where my mind goes with
this series
i thought it was really interesting how
a lot of the relationships that seem to
have started off like oh we're going in
a positive direction
and in a negative and a lot of things
that started off kind of negative ended
up a little bit positive
all that stuff with frenchy and kimiko
i really like that button on the end
because you know kimika wants to get
away from him she slaps him when he
tries to kiss her
but then at the rally uh he stops her
and i thought she would have gotten
killed if she even tried something i
thought she was gonna get like i thought
she's gonna like freeze up get into such
a shell shock mode but then him
preventing her from causing an attack or
something saving her life i thought it
was a really sweet moment do you guys
root for them i love how i'm leading
with kimiko and frenchie here
all the things in the episode to talk
about like let's start with this one
i don't really root for honestly any of
the relationships i just don't feel a
connection to any of them so this
relationship
i mean this episode was a little meh for
me i don't buy a lot of them
um but if there was one to care about it
would be that one i guess the other ones
i'm just like
yeah whatever the romance ticked
department doesn't really
hit yeah but i really did
love how they handled particularly
everything with butcher and becca in a
world that is this fictional
that is the most realistic handling i
think you could have done
with what's going on between them
because that's been a question on all of
our minds
what would butcher do with this boy like
how
how could he possibly father this kid
and make love with each other and that's
like another example
of relation it seems like it's going
who's going to be positive but no
they're it's it's actually going to end
up in a really negative
spot for them both i mean he also didn't
hide his disdain every time the boy was
mentioned he was
almost vomited great performances from
both of them
um because there was so much going on
behind their eyes and facial expressions
that was the main thing to cue you
in on there's yeah there's something
they're not saying to each other right
now there's something pretty dark
happening here
and none of that they're just not having
a conversation about it right here
because they just probably don't want to
yet
you know they want to live in that
little shangri-la as long as possible
which what'd you just say shangri-la
shangri-la god
the vocabulary that's what that word
means
you know he yes i know what it means
he's got a book on his desk
word of the day i think that's it for
today ah
a great magician never shares his
secrets except it leaves it out in the
opinion
for people to see if they want to with a
highlighter i don't understand
in my bookmarks secrets you know as much
as whenever
a huey especially is giving butcher crap
i mean this is libby and i
were always like team butcher all the
way on that particular
argument that they were having on that
debate it's not that i really
side with becca but i 100 get where
she's coming from to the point where i'm
like yeah
i think the decision for right now in
this very moment
this is the decision that you have to go
with you know
it's such a complicated situation that
they have on their hands right now it's
like of course he wants to be with her
but i can't imagine a world where
a character like butcher would possibly
accept
this child and she knew it and that's
why she said it we want to be just
homelanders kid
a soup kid on top of that like oh man
that's just such a
disdainful situation for him to be in
like from his perspective
that's tough but black noir will hunt
him down and that'll be that'd be grand
that they have taken time within this
series to have a character who is
all physical comedy yeah it was just
every time which makes me suspicious to
be honest with you i'm almost wondering
there's something deeper there no one
knows anything about him
he's the one on the team he shuts up and
gets the job done he's hilarious
that makes me feel like maybe he he's
got like a dark past or something
but there was this like really awkward
tension with whoever
that not tech lady surveilling
surveillance lady
yeah there was this kind of ominous mood
he was providing
and he's the only one who's going i want
to find butcher specifically you know
there is something up with him there
that they are definitely
building homelander didn't hasn't asked
him to he was just doing this on his own
so why is he going after butcher on his
own yeah exactly good
call here in intrigues
let's talk about adrian then i remember
when we the last trailer i saw
there was a split second they didn't
even have like dialogue there were just
a frame
i saw a train talking with huey in
starlight and i was like oh [ __ ] is a
train gonna like team up
with huey and starlight and now after
this episode i'm pretty sure it's headed
down that path
he's gonna team up with them or help
them out in some way some part of
element of getting revenge
i feel like with this trajectory is
going all of the seven
excluding maybe stormfront now are all
gonna turn on
a homelander in some way but i've got to
what does that mean for homelander what
the [ __ ] does he care
you know i mean he could just laser them
all on him
he plays you so i feel like yes they'll
turn on him but i feel like he also
won't give a [ __ ] he's scary this was
he's such like he's
so ominous like just the emotions on his
face when you can tell he's getting
angry or angry and you're like this is
terrifying to watch
yeah i mean i really love the way they
handled that last scene though it had me
going of
oh he's gonna do it with himself isn't
he because he has this like little smile
on his face but that's another
flirting with it yeah i mean there's
that's the that's the great um
nuance of his character the writing and
the performer you say though raw the
slightest
wrong thing because he was into it at
first and then the second he mentioned
you're
here to everyone he was like yeah oh no
hell no not having this
like that's i love how elizabeth shoe
came back for the out of all the games
we got a cameo in mind for you i hope
you like it here you go
right here you want to be a fetish for a
nation yeah that's
great paid for that and doppelgangers
obviously this is a situation where he's
you know this is against his own will i
imagine
i mean no he's obviously dead now i'm
saying that i don't he seems like a
prisoner
all the time i want to see how that
started i want to see how that
conversation first arose i need to do
something for me or i'll murder you can
you
can you shove milk down my throat with
your feet
he would have to be on some kind of yeah
like imprisonment lockdown because
imagine if this guy blabbed any of this
stuff about homeland
the most embarrassing like scandal it's
interesting the
the relevance that season one had and
then kind of the
ironic side of how they started working
on season two
way before 2020 and with all the
movements that have been happening in
2020 and then to have your season
of the boys really explore the elements
of
uh you know racism in the world making
this season
more relevant to the time it's coming
out
than than uh even season one because
like season one seemed to really deal
with like a lot of different themes i
guess i wasn't expecting this particular
one to go into that and they even have
like
what was the hashtag that they had here
heroes so white heroes so white
yeah arrows so white and there's just
about to fire there
they're one black they're just fine they
just fired him in homelanders but he's
when he's on television
after he fired a train is saying we have
a train he's black
and black noir he doesn't identify as
anything you know
and
we all know he's not okay with that of
course not of course not
like he's gonna kill her like 100 and
maybe we [ __ ] told you
yeah why would you have a phone call
with her
why would you go back to her you just
endangered her it's all on you i could
understand more of maeve
trying to have this love because this is
already such a conflicting thing for her
she's in the closet about it honestly it
was really that freaking phone call in
the last episode i was like why do you
have this call in the room where
homelander could just show up at any
minute and has like super hearing and
stuff and he even says here
in this episode he says that it was
because of that phone call that he
started to dig
and it's like come on maeve you're
smarter than that really the thing that
gets me the most
on edge about what is possibly stupid
decision making
or actually kind of is is starlight
and huey for a show that is very
self-aware of what it
is there's a side to the store uh
starlight and huey that i have such a
hard time believing
is that starlight i feel like is very
recognizable
she doesn't do anything that different
yes her hair is down and she's in
civilian clothes but her
face is very recognizable huey
was it huey's face on television for
being a fugitive
yeah faces and there's just something
about i know we need to
you know whatever they want to do with
developing romantic entanglement with
them and all that
but it takes me out of it it does take
me out of it and there's this big
logical gap hole that i'm like all right
i'm glad mother's milk is at least
saying
it's dangerous for her to even be here
right now this is when they're like out
in public they're amongst crowds and
they're they're just
chatting with each other kissing each
other like
you this this is not smart this is not
smart and i feel like one of you one of
you should know that what do you would
suppose like
how's this i thought this situation is
terrifying for you and after like
especially homelander threatening
starlight like about to annihilate her
in bot building to me that does actually
that is something with this show that
they've been doing that does pull me out
i feel like they could yeah just work
harder at making it a clandestine
thing for them and make it so that it's
a lot harder for clandestine
that's right and that was the word of
the day yesterday yesterday
yesterday yeah yeah he's learning he's
learning
yesterday yeah check out my vocabulary
stay tuned for tomorrow's word
don't ask me what any of these mean i
don't
he just waits for his moment in this
conversation to insert that word
like plethora this is it this is my word
it's temporaries
this is it it's my time but yeah like i
think comparatively to you guys
experience i i do find
the romantic story lines not
great but charming enough like at least
when there are huges between
sure why not
but anyway no but um i do that is one
aspect of this that does
feel like something that i hope they
hone in and tighten up on
if that is to continue into like a
season three i think one thing that's
good
about the way they approach their
sensibility on this show shows for the
most part they don't seem to
mince words or waste time like compound
v like we said last time could have been
a whole season arc trying to get that to
the people we just
do it in this episode i'm a little
worried about that back and forth
waffling of like we can do this no we
can't
we can do this because i thought the
whole thing about we can't afford to
feel too good for too long or forget
about this i thought that
little nugget of debate was good but
yeah it is sort of a thing where i'm
sitting here going you guys are getting
super lucky
every time you meet up because there are
at least five of the seven
nearby her ending things was actually
the most
realistic where she said we can't do
this again goodbye healy because
of what she went through with homeland
i'm like that was the most realistic
portion
sad i don't even buy homeland or not
believing her
well she didn't lie she did break her
heart
that's true so she technically didn't
lie she wasn't lying
yeah it was a crafty evasion i'll
finally let you guys
oh i'll let you guys have an
you guys have that okay storm front
right here yeah so much she is an awful
awful human being i never know who i'm
who to be more scared
this is a weird thing with the show now
i'm like it's much the storefront at
that one moment
had that point where she was all right i
clearly see i have upset you homelander
i i still don't get the the uh sense
that she's scared
she's just she's just smart yeah she's
way smarter than she
she's really smart and then after some
comments
and some other information has been out
there and then from what the show is
giving you
let's face it for a show from
these filmmakers i think in the comics i
think stormfront is just a straight up
nazi is what a few people have told me
at this point we haven't read the comics
and we don't know what storefront means
okay
we're not on the web 24 7. don't read
alt right right yes
i never read stormfront or breitbart or
any of that
so like with watchmen dealing with a lot
of these kind of things with the
alt-right
racism and then now to see the boys is
also having its kind of commentary on it
as well
that's just the show what it's doing all
right get mad at us for bringing it up
you should be mad at the show
that's right keep your politics out of
my satirical superhero
which is clearly commenting on the
politics yeah
yeah yeah well i thought i really liked
what the road trip amounted to when they
went and spoke to that woman about her
experience with liberty and the sort of
touch reveal dude
yeah and that touch point they both have
of like my dad just one
lone black man trying to go up against
vod they crushed him
me like just a lone black girl going up
against one of these beloved people like
it's a small nugget of the episode but
that is a situation that is incredibly
i would imagine relevant to a lot of
people and that's baked into
so many of the horrific parts of our
society and so you had to touch on that
felt wholly appropriate here and i liked
that whole scene just between those two
actors
i did really like this episode i did i
wasn't necessarily in love with it but i
did like it a lot
i appreciate what they're doing what
they did with mother's milk care like he
had that great monologue about his dad
and then they do
you know he does a lewd that doesn't
live but he explains that his dad died
16 years ago and then you get the
explanation of that later on
and i thought in terms of character
honestly what i usually associate with
mother's milk is he just misses his wife
that's usually the character he misses
his wife and butchers on his nerves he's
just trying to keep everything huge
yeah yeah yeah to get this with him i
thought this was
like for that actor i imagine this was a
really rewarding episode for him he got
some of his best scenes he's ever had
to give here and some great monologue
moments as well i think i would fall on
a similar wavelength to you guys where i
think this one brought me maybe a few
more things that i
uh would get distracted by or whatever
because there's also the thing with
butcher they just completely
skip all the parts where he has to sneak
past all these cameras
like that kind of took me out and i did
think that there was
you know usually the show seems pretty
well paced out and i thought there were
a lot of great moments and great scenes
but this had a wrap around that i
thought was cute but there were it
seemed like the scenes were almost
disproportionately
laid together where some were really
long and involved and others were all
smaller and anecdotal this one had a lot
of really great
moments that i appreciated a lot and i
thought it had a really nice
theme that it did with every character
sure yeah but yeah it did leave me
nitpicking a few things
oh this song seemed to explore i mean
while while of course delving more into
like the racist side of things
but it also seemed to deal a little bit
more with romantic entanglements sexual
encounters which
in some ways made this episode out of
every episode of the boys ever
including season one feel the most like
a soap opera yeah yeah which was a very
different every one of them sex
takes a break to go to bed and then and
then they even and last thing the thing
with the deep
too uh i almost forgot about that with
full-on scientology because
that was kind of just thrown in there
too i like
us not knowing what the interviews were
for but we just get that little bit at
the end you know
yeah it was cute yeah i'm like it's a
very short
here you go snippet of the deep yeah
it's uh that i mean i i like the
the idea of exploring that level of
manipulation you know like oh he found a
woman who managed
i've creating this image for him oh he
found a woman got married
look at him he's really changed his life
around he respects women now you know
yeah when clearly the show lets you know
like the one he was gravitating towards
someone he just wanted to bang you know
yeah it's like i thought that was i
liked that it was cute
because of the way they put it into the
episode it felt like it could have used
some finesse to make it feel like it
belonged
here other than it just happens to
relate to relationships but yeah
continuing on his storyline
i i thought that was pretty funny yeah
you know
this it's strange i was excited for it
to go weekly but i'm actually
i am wondering how that's uh how that
affects the overall viewing experience
of a show that is not designed to be
weekly
we'll see we'll see canceled next year
we never got our jets and actually
people were like really upset like they
were pissed
i think a lot of people weren't given a
proper heads up about it we didn't know
until the day before filming
yeah i was like oh okay yeah you know we
live in a time where
unless you're hbo people kind of assume
that you're gonna put everything out of
one and then for
it's season one to come out as a binge
it's a thing where i'm like guys
let's not get so pissed off at the show
at the same time i get
it i get it i really do get it you know
yeah and i'm waiting to see if this was
truly a good decision
yeah it could just be that this is the
mid season episode you know because we
are halfway through now yeah yeah it's
true
all right guys well overall that's our
thoughts on this episode
what did you guys think leave your
thoughts down below this is the most
youtubery voice i could ever do for an
outro
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell
check us out on patreon last but not
least
michael b over at omni media this is
gonna be the easiest shout out i've ever
had to do in the world
why because if you're enjoying the boys
if you like watching tv show reactions
on youtube as well
he is also covering the boys on youtube
and he covers plenty of other television
shows as well
on top of all that he's just a really
humble sweet human being who one day
michael b
we will go on a double date with you and
john will fifth wheel that [ __ ]
it'll be awkward as hell wishing he was
a huge
his mother's milk in the car he's
chaperoning a slob
billy joel on my watch so yeah buddy uh
thank you so much for
being here for so long keep kicking ass
on your channel
go check out his reactions because i
think you guys would really love it
thank you guys so much and thank you
michael bate